[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORENCE ION:
Hiroshi Lockheimer,
what's a day in the
life like for you?
Do you eat an acai
bowl in the morning?
Do you like to ride
your bike to Google?
What's it like when you get
into the office every morning?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Well,
first of all, hello, everyone.
Good to see you, and
thanks for coming.
Today is Bike to Work Day.
I don't know if
you know knew that.
FLORENCE ION: Oh, is it?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: It
is, actually, at Google.
I don't know.
Is it a US-wide thing,
or is it a Google thing?
I have no idea.
But it's Bike to Work Day.
There's a bunch
of people biking.
I was not one of those
people, because I
live a little bit further away.
And you were asking me,
do I have an acai bowl?
I do not.
I actually don't even know
how to pronounce that word.
I'm just copying
how you said it.
FLORENCE ION: It took me
a while to figure out.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
I drop off the kids
at school in the morning.
I come to work.
And I'm in meetings
all day, basically,
either with the team internally
or a large chunk of what
we do across Android or Chrome.
Chrome OS, Play, we
deal with partners,
whether that's manufacturers
or developers or operators.
So I have a lot of meetings with
internal and external people.
I travel a lot also.
I get to see the world,
which is kind of nice.
FLORENCE ION: I see
your Instagrams.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah.
FLORENCE ION: Yes.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: So yeah, so
that's kind of my typical day,
is meetings, kid
stuff, family stuff.
FLORENCE ION: Meetings,
yes, and good stuff, yes--
exactly, the balance of life.
So there were a ton of new
features announced this week
for Android Q coming out, if
anybody listened to the keynote
the other day.
And you go to work every day.
How did you and
the team figure out
what the heck to put into
the next version of Android?
How do you guys come up with
we need to tackle this feature,
we need to tackle this
setting, that sort of thing?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, I think
it's a combination of things.
We have some ideas,
things that we
want to pursue that we
think are important.
So there's ideas that
we generate ourselves,
but also ideas that come
from our partners, too.
For instance,
manufacturers may say, hey,
we're going to build
a phone that folds.
And then we'll be
like, oh, OK, let's
figure out how that's going
to work from a software
perspective.
Maybe there's a
screen on the outside
and a screen on the inside.
How should these
things interact?
Or someone might
say, you know, we're
going to add a fingerprint
sensor to the Chromebook.
OK, let's support that.
So there's external
influences like that.
There's internal
ideas, as I mentioned.
We also look at feedback
from developers.
FLORENCE ION: I was going
to ask if you're ever
going around the internet--
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Of course.
FLORENCE ION: --and see
what people are saying.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
We definitely do that.
And Steph isn't here right here.
She's not here
right now, but she
runs a process, her and her
team, Steph Cuthbertson,
who was up at keynote.
She meets with developers
regularly and gets a wish list,
if you will.
And she helps prioritize that.
And so your voice really
matters in terms of what we do.
FLORENCE ION: Do you ever use
Android and/or the platforms,
the ecosystem that you
manage, and go, dang,
I really need to fix
that, or we really
need to get people on that?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, I mean, I
think everyone has their own--
I'm a user, too, right?
So I have my own pet things
that I feel a little bit--
like, I'll send
feedback to the team.
I'll be like, why?
Why does this work this way?
And so usually, they say,
uh-huh, and then they just
keep on doing what they're
doing, which is, you know,
great, great for me.
But yes, absolutely, everyone
has their [INAUDIBLE]..
FLORENCE ION: So was that
how Dark mode came about?
You were saying, this
is too darn bright.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
I, personally--
I actually saw that someone
tweeted this yesterday,
and I have to agree.
I'm personally not a
huge Dark mode person.
I don't know if that makes me--
I don't know.
How many of you are
excited about Dark mode?
Yeah, OK, a lot of you are
excited about Dark mode.
So I'm an outlier.
I'm fine with how it
has been, but you all--
your feedback was heard.
And that became sort of
the roadmap item, for sure.
FLORENCE ION: Absolutely.
So I want to switch
gears a little bit
and talk a little bit
about privacy and security,
a particularly hot topic in
this day and age, especially
recently.
So there are a couple of new
features announced on Android Q
to give more control to
both users and developers
to let people decide
when and where their data
and certain elements of the
interface or the operating
system are shared, both with
Google and third parties.
Can you talk a bit about how
and when the team decided
to head into this direction.
How did you all
decide that it was
going to be something as
obvious as just having
a full readout of
permissions and just ticking
on and off what you wanted?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, maybe
I can talk a little bit about--
not to sound dramatic, but a
little bit of the history, too.
Security-- you've mentioned
privacy and security.
Let me talk about
security first.
I think security has
been-- not I think.
I know.
Security has been an important
part of Android from--
I think your question
was about Android,
so I'll answer about Android--
for Android, very
important from day one--
Chromebook OS, too, by the way.
And if you think about
it, the Android team,
we have the benefit of
having seen how computing
evolved throughout the decades.
We saw, for
instance, how Windows
and how security was dealt with
on Windows in the '80s, '90s,
and so on.
So we built this system with
a lot of security built in
from the ground
up, how sandboxing,
or things like that, the
fact that there's even
a Play Store, where we know
who you are as a developer,
and we can have a relationship,
and so on, and have policies--
some of which you may
not like, but at least
we have some ground rules.
And so Android has been
developed with security in mind
from day one.
And so that's always
been important,
and we've been continually
improving on that front.
Privacy is interesting.
It wasn't that privacy
wasn't important before,
but I think how people think
about privacy, in light
of technology,
has really evolved
a lot, especially in
the past year or so.
And I think a lot of us here,
we're all in the tech industry.
We're reading the news.
We're seeing what's happening.
We're hearing about
the conversations.
And so I would say there's
definitely been a renewed
effort around privacy.
Even though it's been
important from before,
I think what's important
and how people think
about privacy has evolved.
So we wanted to adapt to that
and expose new capabilities
and new controls and
transparency urgently.
So that's what we worked on Q.
And it won't end in Q.
Security and privacy
is one of those things, I
think, it will continually
be evolving, and something
that we'll continue to work on.
I think that we took a
big step in Q, however.
FLORENCE ION:
Well, it just seems
to be more part of the
conversation these days.
And I feel like even users
are more aware of what privacy
and security means, and
little devices that we
have in our hands.
Perhaps it's something
that maybe some of us
haven't thought
about until recently.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
well, I think one of the--
even if you have thought
about it, I think--
I'll give you.
Maybe this is I'm going to
get booed for bringing up SMS
and call log.
I know a lot of developers
were a little bit frustrated
with the changes that
we made on that front.
The thinking 10, 12 years ago,
when that capability first-- we
made that available, was, well,
of course, it's a permission.
And the developer asks
the user for permission.
And if the user understands
it, and they say yes to this,
then that's fine.
Because our assumption
was developers
have the user's best interests
in mind, and users understand.
Users and developers
understand each other.
But what I think what we
realized over the past decade
is sometimes that's
not always the case.
All of you have
great intentions,
but there are some
developers that
don't have the best intentions
and will use capabilities
in ways that we hadn't
really anticipated.
An example, by the
way, is there's
different cases
where it's not really
that you're trying to
do anything nefarious.
It's just these capabilities
are not granular enough.
I'll give you an example.
Some of you may have
used the SMS permission,
because you wanted to do
two-factor authentication.
And you just wanted an SMS
to be able to authenticate.
But the whole permission
was like you have access
to everything.
And so it was it
wasn't granular enough.
So we've created APIs for
two factors specifically.
So its scoped to
that purpose only,
and you can't really
use it for other things.
That's the kind of thing that
our evolving the platform.
And so I think our understanding
of the world is evolving.
FLORENCE ION: How
do you figure out
how to make that user-friendly
just for the average user,
versus somebody who may be
a seasoned Android user?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, I think
that's a really key point.
Another thing that
I think we're--
all this sounds
obvious in retrospect,
but it wasn't that obvious
to us 10 years ago,
is what we thought was
obvious to a user, turns out
a lot of these things
were not obvious to users.
So one of the, if
you all remember--
I forget before
which release it was.
But we used to have installed
time permissions, as opposed
to runtime permissions.
And one of the reasons, not the
only, but one of the reasons
why we switched to
runtime permissions
is because we
realized most users,
they are at the Play Store, or
they hit the Install button.
And they're just going
to right away hit
the Accept all permissions,
because they're just
trying to install an app.
They're not really
thinking about--
FLORENCE ION: You should
be using the app, darn it.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah.
And like, why do I have to
decide now whether this app can
use my camera or not?
And it made a lot
more sense in context.
When the user says,
yes, I want to use
a camera, that's when you
get the permission dialogue.
And so these kinds of
things I think we're
learning as an industry, on
how to make it easier for users
to understand and interact.
And I think developers
and the platform provider,
we need to continually
experiment and learn and try
to help users understand.
This is what we do
for a living, right?
We think about technology.
We build stuff.
Most people, that's
not what they do.
Most people are like,
a phone is a tool
to get on with their life.
So they don't want to be
thinking about this stuff,
right?
So how do we make it
easy for them, I think,
is the key point.
And sometimes, I think
sometimes we know too much.
FLORENCE ION: It's also nice
to be able to go back and fix,
if you are rushing through
some dialog windows,
to make sure that maybe the
camera is no longer accessible.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Right, exactly.
FLORENCE ION: Or
your location, too,
which is another big
feature of Android.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
No, that's great.
Yeah, so those are exactly.
Those are, as you
point out, those
are the screens
that we've added,
so that you can go back and
audit and say, OK, what did I?
Who did I give permission to do?
What again?
And you can decide.
Maybe that doesn't
make sense anymore.
And at least,
there's transparency,
and then there's controls.
FLORENCE ION: Absolutely.
So being that this is
a crowd of developers,
and we have a lot
tuning in right now,
what should they know about
these new privacy and security
features and about implementing
them into their apps?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: In terms
of technology, you mean?
FLORENCE ION: Just in terms of
making it friendly for users
who are coming to Android.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
I think that's a key point.
I mean, some of these
things are obvious, I think.
But don't do things that
you don't need to do.
A lot of times--
we do this at Google, too,
where we'll be like, well, maybe
eventually we'll
want this permission,
or maybe eventually we'll
want to be able to do this,
or you asked for these
capability right.
But if you're actually not going
to need it, don't ask for it.
Because otherwise, the user
is going to be confused, too,
and it's just unnecessary.
So things like that, just being
really thoughtful and mindful
about what you're
trying to do, or trying
to scope as much as
possible the access
to the bare minimum of what you
need, I think, is important.
Because people do
notice this stuff,
and it is an important part
of how people, I think,
also decide whether they want
to use an app, versus another.
Yeah.
FLORENCE ION: I like that
idea of mindful developing.
I feel like that's
a good [INAUDIBLE]..
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Just out of curiosity,
how many in the crowd, how many
of you are Android developers?
Well, OK, most of you?
Web?
Yeah, a lot of you also.
OK, other platforms?
Yeah, well, a good mix.
FLORENCE ION: Yeah,
that's a good mix.
So you manage more
than just Android.
You are also overseeing a Play,
and you're overseeing Chome OS.
How do you try to keep
the ecosystems on track?
Is there a shared
ethos or philosophy
that helps drive the
decisions that you all
are making as a team?
And how do you
ensure that you stick
to that philosophy or that
ethos with every new release
of Android.?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
I think one of the--
I'm going to make it
sound very dramatic-- one
of the key insights that we
have is that you all are busy,
and you have a lot
of things to do,
and you have your own
plans and own roadmaps
and own priorities and
maybe your own bosses.
Maybe your own boss,
but you have bosses
who have other priorities.
So the last thing
you want to deal with
is the platform
provider telling you
what your priorities should be.
So we try to minimize
that as much as possible.
Obviously, whenever
we change platforms,
we realize we introduce
work for you--
opportunities, too.
So there's a balance there.
So that's one of the things
that we think about deeply.
So keeping that in mind,
to answer your question,
across Android and
Chrome OS, for instance,
I see Play as being
one unifying ecosystem.
You can run, as
many of you know,
you can run Android apps
on many Chromebooks now.
And that's going to continue.
And that's a way for you
to have your investment,
like in this example,
in an Android app,
be useful in the context
of a different form factor,
even a different
platform, Chrome OS.
And so we're sharing as
much technology as possible
and making it so that,
when you do your work,
it is useful in as many surfaces
or in as many ways as possible.
That's one of the key things.
You're asking, how do
we think about all this?
That's a key thing
we think about.
We also focus a lot--
I was talking to
Steph the other day,
and she was talking about how
it's really important for us--
and we're not always successful
in doing this, especially as
the industry evolves,
but as much as possible,
to keep compatibility.
So that APIs you rely
on today will still
be reliable two years from now.
Obviously, sometimes
we're not able to do
that, especially with--
SNS call log is a
perfect example.
But that's something
that's important for us,
because we know that's
important for you, as well.
And also just
having great tools--
you saw us investing in--
a lot of you are Android
developers, so the [INAUDIBLE]..
We're bringing Android
Studio to Chrome OS.
We announced that
here and made it
really easy for people
to download these tools
and use them.
So those are also areas that
we're investing a ton in.
FLORENCE ION: So as
a platform, Android
has been very open
for a very long time.
Do you feel like it's a delicate
balancing act to just getting
OEMs and others to adhere to
exactly what Android is trying
to do for mobile computing?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, it is.
We have literally hundreds
and hundreds of OES.
FLORENCE ION: Literally
hundreds and hundreds, yes.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yes, and
many hundreds and hundreds
of operators
throughout the world,
and many, many, many developers,
you around the world, as well.
So it's this melting
pot of a lot of--
I mean, we're all interested
in the same thing, which
is being successful
in our businesses
and building creative,
innovative things
and bringing it to consumers.
I think that's what
we're all about,
if I were to simplify it.
But we all have different
motivations and different--
we play different roles.
FLORENCE ION: Right.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: And so we
see, as a platform provider,
we see our role as
being the party that
brings a lot of these
perspectives together.
And sometimes they
don't always line up.
And even, just in
the OEM space, if you
think about we work
closely with Samsung,
we work closely with LG, we work
closely with the pixel team--
who, by the way,
we treat as a OEM.
We treat them as just another
OEM alongside Samsung and LG.
And you name how ever many
OEMs there are in the world,
and they all compete with
each other, these OEMs.
And so they share
their secrets with us,
and we're careful not to share
their secrets with anyone else,
because they're trusting us.
And they have
different opinions.
And so then it becomes our job
to try to figure out the best
way to navigate that.
And I think that's the
same for developers,
the same for operators.
And so we spend a lot of--
I mentioned earlier,
when you asked me
what my typical day is, and
I said, I spend a lot of time
with partners.
That's part of the
reason, is to understand
everyone's
perspectives, understand
what's important for you and for
the operator and for the OEM,
and try to bring it
together that way.
It's fun.
Sundar sometimes
says, you're kind of
like the United Nations.
I've never worked with
the United Nations.
I don't know what that's like.
But I assume-- at least,
I don't know if he has.
FLORENCE ION: I hear
it's a very hard job.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, but that's
what it seems like sometimes.
But it's fun.
FLORENCE ION: When
did you guys decide
that you were going to
you just make Android work
on foldable displays?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
well that, again, that
came up because Samsung--
but Samsung wasn't the only one.
There are many OEMs, some which
have been announced, some that
haven't been announced yet.
FLORENCE ION: I mean, this was
going around for years, it's
been, this idea.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, this
idea, and now it's possible.
And so a lot of OEMs have
approached us over the years.
Another example of this, if
you talk about foldables,
but now it seems like
all phones are like this.
But just a few years ago, the
aspect ratio of most phones
were more sort of square.
They became taller.
They grew notches.
Do you grow a notch, or
do you subtract a not--
I don't know what
direction a notch goes.
But those are all things
that happened roughly
at the same time for
the whole industry,
because that's just how
the supply chain works.
These vendors who
build displays are
able to do this,
and then the OEMs,
the manufacturers
buy these displays.
So that's why they roughly
happen at the same time.
And so foldables, I think,
will follow a similar pattern,
where these display technologies
are now there for OEMs
to adopt in their products.
So in the case of foldables,
they approached us, saying,
we want to do this.
We think we can do it now.
We're worried about
the ecosystem impact.
By ecosystem here,
the OEMs were talking
about you, the developers.
They wanted to make sure
this was easy for you.
They wanted your apps to work
really well on their devices,
hopefully with no work from you.
That's always the hope, is
that you don't want developers
to have to do work.
Because, again, you have
your own work to do.
Why should you have to do
special work for someone else?
That's how they think about it.
And so we work really
closely together with them
on figuring out, how
can we use existing APIs
and make them work that way?
And by the way, just to go
back to one of your earlier
questions, there's
a nice benefit here,
too, because a lot
of that work that you
may be doing for
foldables will be
useful for Chrome OS
your app on Chrome OS,
because re-sizeable
apps and things like
that are very useful.
So again, it's kind of a
two birds, three birds,
one stone type of moment.
That's what we live for.
We like that.
FLORENCE ION: I do want
to talk about Chrome OS.
But before we go there, I want
to ask, what foldable phone are
you using these days?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: I
didn't bring it on stage,
but I am using a Fold still.
FLORENCE ION: OK.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: And I
was actually with some folks
with the press, and they
were a little bit surprised
that I still have one.
The reason why I still have
one is because, well, we
work closely with Samsung.
FLORENCE ION: You're testing it.
You're working on it.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: I'm making
sure these APIs are working,
and so on.
But it's really fun.
Actually, I really like it.
Let's set aside manufacturing
and et cetera for a second--
FLORENCE ION: Yeah, let's
talk about folding phones.
That's a new concept for us.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, it's
really interesting for me.
I found that I'm much more
intentional about when I
use my phone, which surprised--
I didn't expect that.
I thought foldable equals
more screens, bigger screens,
so I'm going to get
lost in my phone more.
But it's actually had
the opposite effect,
because the display
on the outside,
in the same case of the
Samsung device, the display
on the outside, I use it
mostly for quick triage,
if someone sends
me a text message,
and I do need to quickly reply.
Or maybe I'm dealing
with my notifications.
But then, when I actually
want to use my phone,
I'm much more intentional.
Because I physically
open the thing up,
and so it's much less
that I accidentally,
30 minutes later, I'm
still on my phone.
It's much more intentional.
And I actually like
that quite a bit.
And I'm very
productive on it, too.
It's getting a lot
of work done on that.
Because the extra screen
size really does help.
FLORENCE ION: Are you using
it with a Bluetooth keyboard?
Are you doing the
whole little [CLICK]??
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, just a
on-screen keyboard works great.
FLORENCE ION: All right.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: So I'm
pretty bullish on foldables,
in general, not talking
about any specific OEMs,
but just in general.
As a concept, I don't think
it's going to be a fad.
It will take a few
years, obviously.
A, they're very
expensive right now,
and it's not yet available
commercially to buy yet.
So it's going to take a
while for these things
to become more mainstream.
But I think they will.
Remember 3D TVs?
You would go to a store--
FLORENCE ION: Yes.
I remember the three
CESes of the 3D TVs.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Exactly.
I don't think it's
going to be like that.
I think it's going to actually
be a thing that a lot of us
will be using.
FLORENCE ION: Honestly,
I feel like everybody's
feeling the same way
about foldable phones,
just this is a thing
that is going to happen,
and a lot of buzz around
it, a lot of people excited.
I was surprised
by it, but I also
think it's interesting how
quickly Android adopted
the idea of the foldable
to make it say, well, this
is happening, so there you go.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
And by the way,
that is one of the benefits,
if I may, of Android.
It's open source.
You all know this.
And so foldables
or anytime there's
a big disruption or a new
idea or a new technology,
just the open source
nature of Android
and how manufacturers can
take it and modify it and do
what they want to it,
while remaining compatible,
is an advantage
for the platform.
So that's why you're seeing
foldables first on Android.
You're seeing 5G
first on Android.
You saw 4G first on Android.
We talked about it a
little bit at the keynote,
a lot of firsts on Android.
And that's not just bragging.
It's just pointing
out the benefits
of how we've developed the
system and the ecosystem.
Of course, that means a little
more burden in some ways,
depending on how you look
at it, for developers.
Because you're like, oh god,
there's yet another thing.
But it's also an
opportunity for you
to be able to do
interesting things
for various different
types of devices.
And it might unleash
new use cases for you.
FLORENCE ION: It
seems like a lot
of the tools that are
offered for developers
are very thoughtful.
Especially, I've noticed
a lot of things being,
not necessarily sequestered.
But so many little
pieces make up
the OS now to just make it
easy to put in the right puzzle
piece when it needs to
be shined and cleaned,
to offer a metaphor.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, well mainline--
I don't know if you literally
mean it in this sense.
But yeah, we're trying to
modulize the operating system
more.
There are benefits.
There are benefits from
a security standpoint,
update-ability standpoint.
Frankly, there's also
benefits just from--
sorry, this is a little
bit inside baseball--
but within the group.
It's easier for us.
If things are more
modular, it's just
like your code, modular code, is
easier to maintain and release,
and so on.
FLORENCE ION: Copy, paste.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
so there's benefits there.
And so we're definitely
moving more and more
into that direction for sure.
FLORENCE ION: All
right, switching gears,
you are a big user of Chrome
OS, and you are overseeing it.
So Chrome OS has really
increased in popularity
in the last couple of years.
And I personally see a lot
more of it out in the wilds.
And I'm using it
daily to do my work.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Thank you.
That's great.
FLORENCE ION: Well, it helps
that it's being worked on.
So can you talk a little
bit about the trajectory?
Because I mean,
people want to know,
what is the future of
Chrome OS, and especially
about Chrome OS's
favorite color,
which I heard is fuchsia?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: That's yeah.
Wow.
You predicted this.
By the way, Flo and I
were talking earlier,
and I was like, what
are you going to ask me,
like my favorite color?
And she's like, as
long as it's fuchsia.
So she's been trying to get
this in, and I guess, yeah.
FLORENCE ION: Yes.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: So we can
talk about future in a second.
Chrome OS, I'm very
excited about, actually.
Of course, I'm
going to say that.
But I genuinely--
I think Chrome OS
has a real shot,
just to step back for a second.
I think it was developed
in the modern age.
There are many other
computing systems
available for those
form factors, PCs.
But I think Chrome OS had the
advantage of being developed
in a modern age-- again,
similar to Android,
where we were able to learn
from some of the past.
And so security is one of
the most important things,
and a lot of technology is built
into Chrome OS around that.
The statelessness, the
stability, the speed,
the four Ss makes it a really
interesting operating system,
I think, for the
future of computing.
And so we're investing
a lot in Chrome OS.
I think we have a real shot.
Commercially, it's
been doing great.
You said, you know you're
starting to see a lot of people
use Chrome OS.
I see that too, which I'm
super excited to see that.
The PC industry has
been generally flat.
Chrome OS has been
growing like crazy.
In Q4 of 2018 in the US,
we were a little over 20%.
FLORENCE ION: I remember
that stat, yeah.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
And so we're growing.
We're growing significantly.
And by bringing the Play
Store-- and there's also,
if you're a web developer,
obviously, PWAs,
and we have a lot of ideas on
how we can make web apps feel
like native apps, whatever
that means, on Chrome OS,
as well-- so the
best of both worlds,
with the goal of making
this something that people
can use every day as their main
and maybe even only-- like,
that's what I do.
I use a Chromebook--
I use a Pixel Slate,
for what it's worth--
every day as my
primary and only PC.
And then, of course, I
have my Android phones
with me for the
mobile scenarios.
And I think a lot of people,
a lot of you especially,
should be able to
do that already.
And we want pretty much
everyone in the world
to be able to do that, as well.
So developer support,
your support of Chrome OS,
is really, really important.
Like I said, it's
a growing segment,
so really interesting stuff.
And I think we can do some
pretty interesting things.
I feel like the
difference between--
remember when tablets
first came out,
everyone predicted
the death of a PC?
They were like, well,
PCs are going away.
Tablets are going to take over.
But that really hasn't happened.
Tablets are popular, too, but
PCs are still around, too.
So it wasn't a mutually
exclusive thing.
And so I think PCs
are going to continue
to be important
in people's lives,
and I feel like we can do
some very interesting things
around blending touch and
traditional PCs, [INAUDIBLE]
keyboards, detachable
devices, new experiences.
And so you're starting to see
us dabble in that a little bit,
and we'll continue
to invest there.
FLORENCE ION: There's a lot
of little usability tweaks
that you can really
take off from there.
So back to this Fuchsia thing--
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Oh yeah, that's right.
I forgot about it.
Yes.
FLORENCE ION: Can you
tell us anything about it?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, sure.
FLORENCE ION: What's
the ethos behind it?
What do we have to look forward
to as users of these platforms?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Good question.
So Fuchsia, for those of you--
there might be one
person in this room who
doesn't know what Fuchsia is.
Has everyone heard of Fuchsia?
Who hasn't heard of Fuchsia?
Don't be embarrassed
if you haven't.
OK, a few people.
Google has many
projects underway,
and we're a technology
company, so we
invest in various technologies
and experiment, and so on.
And some of those
experiments and investments
we do in the public
as an open source
or as open source projects.
Fuchsia is one of them.
So it's an open source
project by Google,
and it's an investment by us
in modernizing and trying out
new concepts around
operating systems.
So naturally, a lot
of people assume,
well, it's a new OS
from Google, so it
must be the future of
the one OS from Google.
But that's not
how we look at it.
We look at it as a place where
we can try out new ideas.
And so whenever you
see someone saying,
oh, here's a phone
running Fuchsia,
that's really not our goal.
It's not about replacing
Android or replacing Chrome OS.
It is about learning
new technologies.
And maybe Fuchsia
can be launched
on certain form factors,
different form factors.
There are all kinds of devices
that require operating systems.
It's not just phones and PCs.
And in the world of IoT,
there are an increasing number
of devices that require
operating systems
and new runtimes, and so on.
So I think there's a lot of
room for multiple operating
systems with different
strengths and specialization.
So Fuchsia is one
of those things.
And so stay tuned.
We'll continue working on it.
And we enjoy that you
love the intrigue in it,
but there's really
not much intrigue.
It's just more [INAUDIBLE].
FLORENCE ION: Intrigue makes
being a user of these things
fun, because it's much safer
than other types of gossip,
in some cases.
So back to Chrome OS
just as a platform,
are we seeing it go more the
way of the Mac and Windows
in terms of usability
and compatibility
and just like what it can do?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, we're going
to be better than those things.
No, honestly, I think
this is what I'm saying.
I really do think
Chrome OS has a lot
of the guts of being the
future of the next generation
of computing.
We need your support, though.
We need the use cases,
and we need that.
I think you all know this.
People don't buy products
for the operating system.
But much as an operating
system provider,
I want to think that way, the
reality is people buy devices
and products,
because of what they
can do with it, which is where
you come into the picture.
And so I think, with the
right set of applications,
it really has the ability
to be the next generation
of this touch and
keyboard-melded experience,
with new types of form
factors, whether they're
detachables or other things
that haven't been invented yet.
So yeah, I think it is.
FLORENCE ION: Or third
party operating system.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: What
do you mean third party?
FLORENCE ION: Well, oh,
OK, so we have Linux apps.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Oh, I
see, I see, got it, got it.
Yeah, no, for sure,
running Linux,
I mean, Android Studio is a--
the way we're deploying
Android Studio
is a perfect example, right?
It's running in a
Linux container.
I guess from Chrome
OS perspective,
Android is another operating
system in a way, right?
So it supports many runtimes.
The web is one runtime
and I would say,
the primary runtime,
where that's
what Chrome OS started from--
FLORENCE ION: That's a
really good point, yeah.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: --runs
the Android Runtime,
the Linux Runtime.
And maybe there are
others in the future.
As the world evolves, we'll
make sure we can support those.
FLORENCE ION: How do
you balance making sure
that you can support those
things compared to what
is possible with the
hardware that's available,
like processors and
that sort of thing?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
we work really closely
with the industry on this.
We have reference
designs, where we
work with chip providers,
chipset providers, and then
OEMs.
And so we're involved in the
road-mapping of these products.
So we make sure that the
hardware and the software
match, capability-wise.
FLORENCE ION: All right.
We have time for just a
couple more questions.
So I think if we want to
just chat a little bit
about that thing
you said earlier,
about the Play Store being this
unifying link between Android
and Chrome OS--
can you speak to that just a
little bit more, just about
like the vision for that, how
to make it more than just--
because I think a lot
of users, in particular,
see it as just like,
this is the app store.
This is store where
I get my apps.
But how do you
want to explain it
to the people who see it more
than just this is where I get
the apps for my Google stuff?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, well,
I think a lot of people today,
if you were to ask the
people not in the industry,
they would say the
Play Store is where
you get your Android apps.
And this is where
the connective part--
we want the Play Store and the
Android Runtime, if you will,
to be something that you think
of crossing multiple form
factors.
Again, we're talking about
Chrome OS in that context.
So it's the unifying layer.
And what unifies it is these
APIs, the console, the tools,
the policies, all these things.
And this is where we talked
a little bit about privacy
earlier.
that comes into the
picture, as well.
Internally, my group
is known as-- well,
you can see it on the slide--
platforms and ecosystems.
That's how we
think of ourselves.
We pride platforms
and ecosystems,
and Play is the main ecosystem.
FLORENCE ION: Right.
So to round off our
conversation here,
in the spirit of it
being Google I/O, what
was one of your
favorite announcements
that was made this week, just
your personal favorite, maybe
something you were
really excited for people
to hear about, or just something
you're particularly proud of?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Well, a number of things,
I'm not going to cheat and
give you multiple answers.
FLORENCE ION: OK, no problem.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: I do think--
you mentioned that the privacy
topic is an important one.
And I think, especially
for you as a developer,
it's important that we
stay in sync on this
and that we understand
each other well on this
and the motivations behind it.
We want to make sure
that we're adapting
to the modern way in which
people think about privacy,
consumers think
of it, and we want
to make sure we're adapting to
that technologically together.
So I think that's
an important part.
There have been many
sessions about it,
and we talk about
it at the keynotes.
Sundar talked about it
general terms, as well.
So that's, I think,
an important part.
I also think--
I was talking to someone
about this earlier.
A lot of the work that we're
doing that has a positive
impact on people's lives--
around accessibility,
for instance--
I'm really proud of that.
I think that to be able--
FLORENCE ION: Live
Captions is going to be--
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, Live Caption's
a great example, right?
And I think that, Live
Captions, or there
was that video we showed of that
mother in India who now can--
that [INAUDIBLE].
And so I think
these are really--
I know it's going
to sound corny,
but it makes me feel
really proud that we're
able to be a part of
creating that sort of thing.
And many of you do that, too,
through your applications
and through your innovations.
You're helping people.
And I think having
that sense of purpose,
I think, makes it
really important
and makes me feel
like we're working
on important stuff,
which is fun.
It's always easy
to get caught up
in, like, how many
gigabytes, or how many what?
How many lines of code?
But really just stepping
back and thinking, like, OK,
we've helped people
accomplish something--
that's really important.
FLORENCE ION: I would
say, at the same rate,
the technical achievement of
being able to whittle down
2 gigs of data into just
merely kilobytes and files is
really neat.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yes, the language model?
Yeah, that's very cool, yeah.
FLORENCE ION: Did that have
anything to do, by the way,
with Now Playing?
Was that derived from that?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
No, I don't think.
FLORENCE ION: It
sounded similar to me.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
It's similar in concept
in that they're both on device.
These models are on device, so
it's not leaving the device--
similar in that sense.
But yes, they're very
different domains.
And that one's music,
and one's words--
but yeah, very similar
concept in that sense.
FLORENCE ION: All
right, we're just
about nearing the end here,
so I feel like, you know what?
It's the last day.
Let's be a little
philosophical and dreamy.
So look into your crystal ball
for Android and the platforms
that you manage.
What are you just really looking
forward to in the future,
beyond a little beta that
we have going on right now?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, I
think it's rewind a little bit,
right?
If we think back to even just
five years ago, or maybe even
less, we're doing so many
things on our devices,
whether they're
phones or laptops
or whatever, home devices.
We're doing things
on these devices
that really, we couldn't do
before, where we would talk
about it in the abstract,
like, wouldn't it
be cool if you could do this?
Well, we can now do a
lot of these things.
And so I'm excited
about the future
in terms of just not
even knowing where
these things are going to head.
There's just so
many opportunities,
and we have, I think,
the right foundations
in place, the right
security and privacy
mindset, the right mindset
around helping users,
and all that.
With that in mind, how to
evolve technology together,
with the OEMs, with
you as developers,
with the network providers--
a lot of possibilities,
that gets me really excited.
FLORENCE ION: Hashtag The
Possibilities Are Endless.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
There you go.
FLORENCE ION: Thank
you so much, Hiroshi.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Thank
you very much, appreciate it.
FLORENCE ION:
Appreciate your time.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: And
thank you all for coming,
and hope you enjoy
the rest of I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]